all right so sherry's off today your
most accurate weather now forecast we've
been following the progress
of the sunrise officially a few minutes
ago from our camera top of the red rock
resort a couple of breezes there and
still some clouds around
and still very warm officially 91 but
how hot is it where
you are we had readings in the upper 90s
just an hour ago so things are dropping
for just a brief period because things
are going to start cranking back up
91 right now is the cool spot for
aliante also in green valley i take that
back there's seven hills and anthem at
88 same with mountains edge
and rhodes ranch we will see some more
storm clouds around this afternoon
but we're not expecting any rainfall we
may get dry
lightning which would be bad news for
wildfires
death valley had 128 yesterday
dropping to 104 from 108 an hour ago
86 over the hump and trump 79 there in
sandy valley
50 sounds great up in ely right about
now
but that's not happening down here
yesterday we set two
new records 114 the high beating the
previous record of 113 from 1940
yesterday's low of 90 the record for the
warmest overnight low beating 87 from
2008 so today
we're going for 114 one shy of the
record but
way above normal our current temperature
is the uh
low so far that's probably going to be
another record
we'll watch for those storm clouds this
afternoon possibility
of a tropical storm and even if it
doesn't get to be a name storm
they're looking at a foot of rain along
the gulf coast so here we are with 114
today and tomorrow we may tie the record
tomorrow
dad's day no threat to the all-time
record of 117
but still very hot we may slip down if
you want to call it that to 103
by a week from today